get ready for a fast and furious dose of
summer action reviews are racing in for
Hobbs and Shaw a standalone spinoff
presented by The Fast & Furious
franchise it's generally agreed that the
film delivers exactly what it promises
plenty of high-octane
over-the-top set pieces held together by
lots of witty banter and some serious
chemistry between its two leads with 102
reviews counted the film currently
stands at a 72 percent average on Rotten
Tomatoes Hobbs and Shaw finds our
titular duo teaming up to eradicate a
serious threat brixton Laura trade buy
Idris Elba is a super-powered terrorist
and self-proclaimed black Superman
intent on unleashing a potent virus on
the world bad guy back in January star
Dwayne Johnson promised that the film
will be the biggest showdown The Fast &
Furious franchise has ever seen well it
certainly has the right pedigree it was
pinned by Chris Morgan the screenwriter
behind the Fast and the Furious Tokyo
Drift Fast & Furious Fast Five Fast and
Furious 6 Furious 7
and the fate of the Furious suffice to
say this man knows exactly what fans
want meanwhile director David leach is a
co-director of the action-packed
original John wick and also delivered a
similarly off-kilter blast of craziness
with last year's Deadpool 2 according to
critics leech and company have delivered
an exciting entertaining action film
that takes full advantage of the
crackling chemistry between Johnson and
co-star Jason Statham they also praised
the performances by vanessa kirby and
Elba on the other hand the film's
detractors focused on the outlandish
action sequences but what did they
expect
Entertainment Weekly's Leah Greenblatt
understands that the bonkers action is
exactly the point writing that Hobson
Shah is a testosterone mother load so
relentlessly ridiculously adrenaline it
doesn't so much unfold as steadily
defibrillate you body's crumple metal
clangs and anything that doesn't get
punched or shot or stabbed on sight just
stands by patiently waiting to explode
when it's not all completely brain
numbing it's actually pretty fun it
sounds like Brian Tallarico of Roger
Ebert calm was perfectly content letting
the film's kinetic energy wash over him
what her audience is really here for
they want some banter between stars
Jason Statham and Dwayne Johnson check
they want them to beat each other up a
few times check a physics-defying car
chase or two would be nice check and
check elsewhere in his review Tallarico
claimed the truth is that the summer of
2019 has been ridiculously thin when it
comes to mindless fun and there's
something to be said for merely bouncing
for movie stars as charismatic as this
film's quartet off each other for just
over two hours Cleveland Plain Dealer
Chuck Yarborough was clearly a fan of
the film effusive Lee gushing that Hobbs
and Shaw is one of the most entertaining
action movies you'll see this year what
makes this film work is the humor that
pours from Johnson and what he's able to
elicit from his fellow actors
particularly good are the insults in
what we used to call the slip fights
between him and Statham of course plenty
of critics walked away from the film
with a sour face and there's no shortage
of snarky reviews out there Donald Clark
of the Irish Times sniped after just
half an hour I was tempted to spread
foam across the screen and scrape off
the stubble that was already breaking
through the awful banter is something
else neither man has to be fair much to
work with
Jake Wilson of the age unleash plenty of
scorn on Morgan's screenplay in its
plethora of quips the action regularly
grinds to a halt so Hobbs and Shaw can
trade elaborate put-downs which give
every sign of having been crafted by
writers whose practical experience of
brawling has occurred mostly on Twitter
keenly demonstrating how to effectively
put someone down Wilson goes on to say
for the leading men everything appears
to be business as usual which hardly
needs saying in the case of Statham a
cook who knows just one dish
nevertheless most critics were more than
willing to
except the film on its own terms Candace
Frederick of the rap embraced the
absurdity of the blockbuster writing
that the film is very cognizant of what
it is which is also in line with what
Fast and Furious has always been an
opportunity for Alfa men and women to
exchange insults then eventually hug it
out for the sake of some good
old-fashioned whoop-ass so that's what
the critics had to say now it's time to
make up your own mind Fast and Furious
presents Hobbes and Shaw opens on August
2nd and we're expecting to be
electrified three sharks will kill a man
there we go check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]